هذا هو عدد 1.3 مليون برميل
بما يتماشى مع ما يحتاجه السوق اليوم
بالنظر إلى تكوين المخزونات
في الولايات المتحدة والتباطؤ المحتمل
في عام 2019 لديه عدد من الافتراضات هي
أن أحدها يقوم بإصلاح 25
دولة الآن نعرفها هناك  هو
رأي إجماعي مفاده أن العديد من البلدان الأعضاء لدينا في
حالة انخفاض فعليًا ، لذا
سيتم توفير جزء من 1.3
للسوق من خلال الانخفاضات غير الطوعية ، لذا
فإن العيوب التطوعية إلى حد ما
هي واحدة من القضايا التي يتعين علينا
مناقشتها اليوم أن نكون واضحين بالرغم من ذلك  هل
أنت مرتاح لعدد يبلغ حوالي
1.3 مليون برميل يوميًا من أجل
المصداقية حيث أن السوق ينخفض
مًا إلى هذا الاجتماع أعتقد أنه مف
ط إذا أخذت في الاعتبار ما
أيناه بالأمس عل
سبيل المثال من كندا أو اليوم ال
ابق مع المصنع 50000
أو ما يقرب من ولاية
ألبرتا ، أعتقد أنه إذا أخذت في
الاعتبار التخفيضات غير الطوعية من
قبل بعض زملائنا وبلدانهم ،
فإن العدد  أننا نحتاج اليوم إلى
بعض أكثر من ذلك لتحديد تلك
الأرقام التي قد توحي بها
الروح التي تستخدمها الولايات المتحدة.  يمارس تأثيرًا لا داعي له
على الرغم من أنك قلت إن
لديه رأي الرئيس ترامب هذا ،
حيث يُنظر إليه على أنه تأثير لا داعي له ويتأرجح معك لتتراجع
مع أعداد الإنتاج
بدلاً من أن تكون أعلى بشكل جيد ، أعتقد في
نهاية اليوم أننا دول ذات سيادة
ونحن '  سنقوم باتخاذ القرار بناءً على
المصالح الفضلى لبلداننا
بالإضافة إلى إيماننا بالمصالح الفضلى
لمستهلكينا والتي تشمل
الولايات المتحدة ، لذلك سنأخذ مساهمته
في الاعتبار مثل المنتجين الرئيسيين الآخرين
والدول
النامية المماثلة  ضعيف للغاية
ويحتاج إلى طاقة ميسورة التكلفة لمواصلة
النمو خاصة خلال عام 2019 حيث
توجد العديد من الرياح المعاكسة للاقتصاد العالمي ،
وسيتم أخذ كل هذا في
الاعتبار